ce voyage à Calcutta j'ai toujours dit
c'est le voyage qui change ma vie et
c'est comme quelque chose de très fort c'est-à-dire mais
était si
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les conversations et les moments que j'ai eu
seul en silence avec elle
cadeaux que la vie te donne je me souviens
être là avec elle elle avec ses yeux
fermé une demi-heure les deux dans une chambre
seul et
Et j'hallucine beaucoup, dis-moi, fais-moi un cadeau
donne la vie que je prends d'ici
et le jour où il a mis les fronts sur moi et sur les
chérie m'a dit aide toujours qui
vous pouvez à tout moment avec n'importe quoi
même avec quelque chose de petit mais toujours
essayer d'aider bien sûr la force n'est pas
juste savoir ce qu'elle est et que tu es
impressionné par qui elle est mais
quand tu les as devant toi et c'était tellement
spécial et m'a dit de telle manière
jolie et si forte bien sûr que j'avais
vu des lieux de grande pauvreté lors de voyages
dans des endroits difficiles mais c'est vrai que
Calcutta quand elle a dit qu'ils sont les plus
pauvre des pauvres c'est vrai que c'est
un des sites
où tu peux voir plus de choses bestiales
J'ai ramassé des bébés dans la rue et je suis allé chercher
là pour retrouver ses parents qui étaient
mendiant dans la rue voisine mais
bébés d'un mois alors quand ça
vous habitez là juste en face de votre
yeux de cette créature et jeté aussi clair
qui te change pour que tout change tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce fut aussi une révolution pour moi
Je suis tellement obsédé par lui
film de pouvoir travailler avec lui quelques
jour où je suis parti voir ce film et il m'a donné un
marcher et là j'ai décidé d'aller en chercher un
les gens vont trouver une école de théâtre
Je suis entré dans Cristina cassé pendant quatre ans
et c'est là que j'ai vu un petit panneau accroché
de nouveaux visages voulaient les tests de
nouveaux visages de katrina bayonas et je suis allé
J'ai fait trois fois pour le troisième moi
baisé trois fois en deux semaines et je
je suis de retour je suis de retour tu es tout petit amour et c'est
bien la semaine prochaine fils
Pareil cette semaine je suis revenu et je pense
qui frappe déjà
il m'a donné un test un troisième test et
J'ai eu toute la colère d'elle
Elle m'a manqué parce qu'elle était petite
et puis ils ont vu la preuve qu'elle était avec elle
équipe et ils m'ont appelé et nous avons commencé
travailler ensemble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je ne le connaissais pas quand il a vu ma belle
époque et jambon jambon m'a appelé par
téléphone et je ne pouvais pas y croire
à l'extérieur de lui quand j'ai entendu sa voix c'était comme
aller rêver qui s'accomplit si précisément
Je n'en avais pas tant rêvé et il
rencontré chez lui et je suis allé le voir ainsi qu'un
le béguin était la façon dont cet homme vit déjà
Je sais c'est pas d'où mais c'était déjà
une relation si forte et une chose
mutuelle parce qu'il m'a toujours dit que
il a eu la même chose avec moi et nous
nous voulons beaucoup, c'est comme quelqu'un à moi
famille mais le fort quand tu
passé avec quelqu'un comme ça depuis depuis
premier jour, il m'a dit que je t'écrirai un
personnage bientôt qui vous conviendra comme
un corps qui était ce qu'il m'a écrit dans
une note qui m'a fait très plaisir
et puis appelez-moi pour de la viande tremblante
pour ce personnage qui était petit mais
c'était magnifique là où j'ai accouché
un bus avec la femme qui est aujourd'hui ma
belles-mères coïncidences qui ne sont pas
des coïncidences pas très fortes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était une énorme montée d'adrénaline
aussi pour le premier de la nuit je
J'étais avec ma mère et
C'était très fort parce qu'à ce moment-là
tu ne penses qu'au cul je peux dire
tout ce que je veux dire sans me tromper
et ne pas tomber au sol dans un autre bras de poisson
[Musique]
si c'est un état de nerfs si fort
qu'à ce moment-là, ce que tu veux, c'est que
vous savez à ce moment et rien d'étrange ne se passe
pouvoir le dédier au peuple
auquel vous voulez le consacrer était important
pour moi de parler un peu en espagnol
remercier en espagnol
et je me souviens alors sors de là passe
ces couloirs comme si j'étais dans le
lune comme avec un vertige de je ne comprends pas
ce qui se passe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh bien je pense qu'il s'est sûrement transformé
toute la façon de voir la vie
la maternité change tout de
moment
et bien sûr j'ai interprété beaucoup
mères avant d'être mère et croyait que
je les ai très bien compris
et je les ai compris mais bien sûr maintenant c'est un
un autre niveau est
parce que ta vie change déjà le chemin
tout voir tout sentir et sûrement
a affecté la façon dont je
je les ai interprétés